[Music]
a new documentary series explores both
the historic career of bill cosby and
his descent from america's dad to
alleged sexual predator in 2018 bill
cosby was convicted of three counts of
aggravated indecent assault and was
sentenced to prison he denied the
allegations last year the pennsylvania
supreme court overturned that conviction
due to a procedural issue which prevents
him from being retried for this case the
court did not make a ruling on the
allegations cosby first rose to fame in
the 1960s with a stand-up comedy then in
1984 his hit sitcom the cosby show
solidified his reputation as america's
dad dr cliff huxtable the four-part
documentary we need to talk about cosby
takes an unfiltered look at his complex
legacy the series features interviews
with women who allege the sexual assault
happened by cosby it also includes
comedians journalists and academics like
jelani
you don't often learn
that your heroes
are
really the worst sorts of villain
like that's not something that's a
normal experience
um or that this person who you think of
as a hero
has fooled
the entire country
about what their character really is
w kamau bell is the director and
executive producer of the series he
joins us now kamau good morning as i
said to you before we started covered
this case both trials
i noticed that you said earlier this
docu-series feels like it could end my
career and many times while making it i
hoped it would just go away so why this
film why focus on bill cosby i mean you
know i was born in the early 70s so my
whole life bill cosby has been part of
the wallpaper of black america and
because of the kind of program he was
doing as a kid it was aimed at me the
fat album the cosby kids picture pages
the electric company it was all stuff
that i was seeing all around my life and
so i grew up and then became a stand-up
comedian in large part because of bill
cosby himself and the cosby show felt
like i was a member of the family and so
when i found out what we all found out
and i believe that the women were
sexually assaulted and raped that
how do you hold on to this and as black
folks it's a conversation we've been
having amongst ourselves a little bit
but i feel like this was the time to
sort of bring it all together at the
time he had been putting sent to prison
what we thought was going to be for but
as you point out in your documentary you
said you are used to difficult
conversations yeah on my show united
shades of america on cnn you know
famously my first episode was with the
ku klux klan so this is like
somehow it's become part of my brand to
have difficult comments what do you want
us to get out of it because listen you
you you really went all the way there in
terms of the people you interviewed and
the things that they said i thought were
stomach turning
some of the things i hadn't heard before
i mean there's a couple things one i
think a lot of cosby's career involves
the history of black america in the 20th
century roland martin makes that point
and i think we don't want to throw that
away because there are important things
like cosby integrating the blacks the
stunt industry for black people yes and
the other part of it is this is bigger
than cosby like powerful men in media
sexually assaulting harassing raping
women is a story that is not
one man one network we all know it
happens all throughout the industry
everywhere where we sit so the idea
being that we have to
figure out how to create a safer
industry in four parts you spoke to a
lot of people um but you didn't speak or
reach out to cosby's camp and they
commented and said that they're having a
bigger statement tomorrow
but basically called this baseless uh
and had problems with the fact that they
didn't um
have any input i guess in this film i
mean uh bill cosby and his camp has been
very clear about where they stand on
this and this to me was about reckoning
with the legacy and reckoning with what
we can learn from this and i think we
have clips of bill cosby throughout to
show what he thinks about these things
and how he feels about these things it
didn't feel like if you're going to put
the survivors in here that you also then
put bill cosby in here at the time when
you were shooting it did you think the
bill cosby story was over because when
you started he was actually in jail yeah
it seemed like he was going to be in
jail for the rest of his life is at his
age which is so i thought this is the
time we can have the conversation the a
recurring problem in america is it's
never time for the conversation
so he got out and it felt like maybe the
whole film goes away but it's like the
conversation is still relevant
it's still i'm trying to create a space
if you don't want to have this
conversation there are plenty other
things on tv for you to watch but i
think there are large terms of people
and specifically black folks who are
ready for the conversation i think a lot
of people are ready for the conversation
and i think bill cosby is only going to
drive people to the documentary if he's
going to come out tomorrow and give a
big statement about it as you just
mentioned i was curious though that some
people who you invited to sit down did
not want to do it is that because they
wanted to continue to live with the myth
or the image of cosby or because they
were afraid of a backlash from the cosby
camp but what's that calculation like
all of that and more everybody has a
different calculation i had some
incredible conversations with people
that were like hour-long conversations
where they said no
i had some incredible conversations
where they said maybe they turned into
no that was very helpful i'm not going
to say who those people are it's up to
them to decide if they want to talk but
this is a third rail conversation for
everybody because he was america's dad
yeah in just about every person that you
interviewed everybody started with a big
deep sigh like oh no here we go i don't
want to but i'm going to go there did
you find that there were still women who
this had happened to but also didn't
want to come forward yeah i mean he
there as we know there's over 60 women
who've come forward saying he's
assaulted or raped them and we didn't
talk to near that many now we couldn't
have but also many we asked said no
because they feel like first of all
every time they talk about it they're
going to be subject to attack
so they they feel like i've done that
enough i don't need to do it again are
you worried about the incoming that's
sure to come your way now from the cosby
camp and still the people that support
him oh sure sure you plan to deal with
that how or your thoughts about that or
what i mean i don't know what to prepare
for other than be prepared so you know i
know it's coming tomorrow it's also my
birthday tomorrow everybody agrees
everybody in the documentary calls me as
a tremendous entertainer right that's
beyond dispute yes what do you say to
people at home uh what how where do you
come down on the question of do you
continue to consume that entertainment
can you watch him or i mean i watched
him a lot to make this documentary and
there's a segment where we talk where we
talk about the the night time is the
right time the ray charles lip sync that
the family does in one of the early
episodes and when i watch it i connect
to that kid i was who was like blown
away by this and when i watched watch
him now
we do that all the time and we all
separate the art from the artist all the
time i think if i if i and but if i
watch cosby i'm still doing in the
context of the bigger story and you have
three daughters i have three dogs this
means even something yeah at some point
this will stumble across their faces and
i will have to explain to them this is
good
in an age-appropriate way this is the
bigger story wow how did you feel when
it was over when you had talked to the
people that you talked to
there were so many moving poignant
moments in this documentary it doesn't
feel over like it feels like it i mean
it's i don't i don't know when this is
going to feel like it's over but it
doesn't it feels like it's just
beginning because the conversation that
is important is not the doc it's the
conversation after people watch it and
you said you want to create a safe space
you left the documentary saying i want
women to feel safe it's about come
forward and speak it's about
specifically the entertainment industry
looking at itself and going how do we
create more safety and accountability
and then america as a whole how do we
make victims and survivors of sexual
assault feel like they can get justice
and healing in a way that they don't
feel now it's still underreported
thank you very much i started out
watching one episode and before i knew
it i watched all four of them it's very
very powerful and very well done thank
you congratulations
and happy birthday to you tomorrow
bell thank you for coming in person in
the studio you can watch we need to talk
about cosby it starts this sunday at 10
o'clock on showtime which by the way is
a division of viacom cbs we'll be right
back